[Music]
guys the same day we are in New York and
we are at Nintendo's with launch press
event I'm having chemo spend time ever
[Music]
varmints go up a few songs trying to
kill yourself or your friend give me a
powerup drop more bomb this feels really
good to you oh you know it's a broken
toe ball shoot okay right now
you know I try to kill you I've been
strategically planting bombs to kill you
varmint coop now that we know the
objectives look I like the lawn
I like to see through walls as well yeah
[Music]
all right we're about to play one two
switch
[Music]
I'm going to need to do a little
practicing on my face
[Music]
we just like quick-draw I mean you got
my path there I know I'm hoping it to
milk the definite are about to play the
milking yeah
[Music]
wow you're real gettin this thing that
smells like okay I'm bill
Jeff Annette have already milk I like it
[Music]
I like this one cause this one's called
four pounds Oh
we're about to play Wall County
basically it's account how many marbles
we think are in really instrument ocean
so you're just going to be holding it in
your hand you've got a box going to use
the paddock okay how about anything I'm
still counting there's no net
look I'm playing - oh hey hi
right oh my goodness how are you I'm
great
that's good I'm really happy to see you
I'm happy to see you so how's it going
are you playing this nah no I mean I hit
you but we're not going to play it what
it's like yeah I'm playing Skylanders
it's not snotlout's like to see you I
just like what's on open controller oh
yeah but no it's it's pretty awesome
I'm super excited and I thought you
started getting into gaming now more
scripts every time okay
see my gaming setup it's really next
level now it's on your Nintendo folks is
like it's really cool I just don't have
like a Nintendo there yet you know hey
it's a Linda Michaels third goalie
what a night he's taking it's okay
they go it look good your baby is
Delphia and while taking a selfie of us
something like that alright leash
Islanders we played once you quit and
now I think we're going to try to play
network equipment this was when it was
never a bit limitless I said like 500
everything was the official name zipper
clips
cut it out together okay you guys you
aren't in here for a sub the official
name because I completely mess it up
[Music]
okay so this game is actually
surprisingly way more fun that I was
thought it was going to be with a name
like dipper Clifty great so good it's so
fun
cut it out together Wow different
neighborhood
okay a long time ago they came to my
house and down we just danced for a Def
Jam commercial yeah fun dance complete
forever golf
gallopers the universe full circle
[Music]
Mario Odyssey is pretty much what
everybody is waiting for they don't have
a playable here but I have a feeling you
know probably be playable extreme my god
I miss mario so like
I'm a sneeze good I ran out Liguori
yeah just about to meet in toes I'm the
best
so what they haven't right cause
everybody knows I hit rock Mario diner I
will play Mario Kart we're playing we
all playing together and play together
I'm sorry I don't want to see this
painting
Marquart April playing so I like playing
like like we're putting a table there
forever yes and my friends when we like
we're actually playing you can like look
up and like ah you remember my Mario
Cart birthday party where we had two TV
set up your aunt's to TV set up next to
each other and then we had to we use
connected and it was what it struggles
and now I feel like everybody can just
bring this to one person he'll like
those roles if you get a break easy
I'll be running in so many of my
wonderful internet friends I don't have
you been in a lot of my not know this is
the first time or everything this might
be great great so how getting going so
good by the way I gotta say I'm a
youtuber you're one like the inspiration
like dead serious oh my god everything
comes full circle now we're going to end
oh that's crazy
I mean you create by far some of the
most incredible videos ever every time I
watch one it's like I'm like how how how
how
I am super honored and big fan I love
watching you behind the scenes videos
both by makers me I'm like I want to
know what you're doing hell is happening
well thank you hi Mona we love doing it
so it keeps us busy out of trouble for
the most part so we're getting
Tenderfoot what do you think I'm mine
well I played Sonics I'm like a big
saucepan I want to say Mario but it's
not out yet and I'm so excited about
Zelda and I get an interview Miyamoto
oh my god two minutes
I gotta go in a couple minutes but I
like going Friday my god it's going to
be great
incredible they told me yesterday it
starts crying so I'm so happy so we'll
have fun and I'll see you on foot so
good question
alright guys that's in here for the
antennas event I had a really lovely
time I had so much fun I'd like know
what such was like cool I just spent a
whole day with it and now I don't get to
play with it until March 3rd I did do a
pre-order i pre-ordered it from that
side
I tried Best Buy and then I couldn't try
Amazon I couldn't I got it at Walmart
and it enjoyed that good-looking about
work my sister she works the targets
that she said it goes are you so this
hard if they have them I did also get
another Praetorian at Walmart so I've
got all the bases covered whichever one
gets there first
that's what we're doing alright guys
thanks for watching I'll see you later
Michael Jackson we've got some really
bad news guys we are sold out of them
right now no loving 2017 that's my
hashtag so right now we're going to be
heading to the Nintendo switch launch
stream so that's why were here in New
York pretty excited do you think you
Nintendo for inviting me out here for
all of the fun so I cannot